alright let's try it boom you have to
track it down lightning 6390 this is the
first time I'm doing this type of a
tournament what kind of tournament is it
you ask it is for one not a war zone and
we're already going to be kicking up so
six players this is a our five players
are in so they'll be a by ah round one I
have won my tournament game by default
because your opponent was not there
that's what happens when you have an odd
number of players so this is how it's
going to work these are Fisher random
games you start with ten seconds but
when you make a move you gain one second
so these games can end very quickly you
start out with ten seconds it's Fisher
random when you make a move you gain a
second this should be interesting to see
game over boom white wins no time not
fast enough so we're waiting for round
two these are gonna happen here we go
here we go here we go here we go i was
really double the points what should i
do i can't think very long there's five
four three then i have much time neither
do i let's take this I grab that night
oh I had that I could take that you're
still in check tricky nights now tricky
nights queenside Castle queenside castle
nine seconds oh boy am i doing oh I
could take this pins to pin i have this
seven seconds with increment communes
pin that's what check this is close to
me this is another check most likely now
we have check here i could grab the rook
for free first i'll do the bishop
there we know they didn't resign their
down on time whoa those are quick games
round three coming up soon 960 you start
off in a random ah this is ridiculous
they're saying now on the x player for
this round and I get one point and we'll
play again in the next round okay I
didn't play in round one I played it
round two and now I'm not playing in
round 3 but guess who has 3 i'm still
getting points okay let's sneak up on
somebody sneak attack oh i guess that
round is finished my time is ticking
let's go here Dylan Dylan is on the
scene I could cast as soon as I moved my
night let's get this guy involved my
dark square Bishop wants to play my
Dykstra Bishop is playing can't deal
with that part the pond pushes what
would have happened I would have been in
I would have been in trouble much time
take their open this up okay that pond
is going to have some problems ponds
going to have some problems forks that's
a fork I got this this uh what am i
doing just move six seconds okay stop
that night okay I could have just given
a check you give a check now anything
drop back for a second King position
that night can't move now he's in a pin
got to get rid of that tricky night
tricky night seven seconds got this more
files opening up rook activity if you
got to be an easier way let's get this
pawn take the night next eight seconds
have another pawn another pond give me
that night give me that night god
finally he's got it's easy to pre move
now these guys want to play as well it's
easy with the increment once you're in
one of those type of positions where you
could just pre move the rest of the game
there's are going to be one more round
waiting for round five what are the
standings Oh we'll see soon enough this
is I believe the last game very fast
tournament Sicilian oh no oh no that
could be made soon so maybe I'll try to
do the same nah not quite some type of
Sicilian and get my bishop out night
right there would have been good i think
get my pond up so my queen could breathe
okay it's a bit closed pod push like
here I hear next I don't have any time
whoa is that first place confetti that
was the fastest first place confetti
ever whoa haha I was different good
games ah a little fun there with Fischer
random one minute are actually not even
one minute chest 10 second with the one
second increment that was different
alright could games all